could I make a better shower um it's
gone this guy see the [ __ ] oh we
don't need the [ __ ] anymore we have
the good shooter
um okay well she's peed up so we're
gonna craft another mask [ __ ] unless we
just say [ __ ] it and let her go if I
could let her go
to focus s shelter what's like not too
far from us okay getting this equipped
can you put this too oh [ __ ] not [ __ ]
you I want talk shows on a mask
um Perry yes we can trade
[ __ ]
how is this guy and how is this guy you
fix this Lisa you gotta sleep we're
doing insanely well Matthew left what a
[ __ ] idiot good luck out there
Matthew Oh what the [ __ ] who is that
Jesus [ __ ] it all [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ]
yeah and should we just make a [ __ ]
Tim sound for whatever's there ooh
restaurant garlic [ __ ] it let's just
take all this [ __ ] the par like
everybody no [ __ ] coffee I know ed
any coffee don't need cement
[ __ ] so much stuff is going on cuz
Hammond items it's good this is good oh
we need [ __ ] we need a lot of this stuff
switch buccaneer switches
man this is getting crazy [ __ ] a
[ __ ] we need so much of this stuff
kind of hard to maintain this [ __ ] oh
all the [ __ ] over here uh-oh [ __ ] a
ferocious looking creature some pair
[ __ ] we gotta kill this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
hey Jay says oh good good good oh good
good good you really [ __ ] that one up
yeah cha was gone up good [ __ ] [ __ ]
the guys are all just sitting around why
don't you [ __ ] fix some [ __ ] yeah
clean some [ __ ] dad clean this [ __ ]
place
and
what does the Shannon is like an expert
level
yes
[ __ ] we don't pretty good he'll get this
engine pipes okay so what can i recycle
hear how the output
okay let's see here
TV oh [ __ ]
ok I just need a pipe in a hinge fix
this [ __ ] Jess
more water [ __ ] you are plastic
should be cool hmm
take it out Freya this
lens switch duct tape would
ok let's guy can broadcast for traders I
need pipe or hinge ok nine hours
great now we got so much fuel
who's that guy what the [ __ ] 1 2 3 4 5
[ __ ] get a little tight out here so I
can I am moving I was gonna wait for
traders what corpse are they talking
about Greg's waiting for her is there
clean the shelter [ __ ] here's someone
what you got um I don't need any of this
ah get the [ __ ] out of my face doc come
back
Carrie help people here yes let's see
what you got see what you got yep ideas
eventually you know [ __ ] it you know
[ __ ]
we got a lot of this [ __ ] yes what the
[ __ ] and then burn [ __ ] haida broadcast
for traitors get good good good kill
there's a wasting time here this little
kid can go harvest this door is this
ding ah you don't need this [ __ ]
okay we got to go back out there where
you got to go to restaurant restaurant
restaurant medium house guess when I
will check this place out
good luck out there
hey
let's see what they got I need some
stuff achieving can you help I think
there's a pretty dangerous type there
already so you might want to go in
shooting if you catch my drift ooh
already jesus is the patient guy [ __ ]
a they have [ __ ] weapons bleep phooey
oh there's three of them come on come on
yes Oh schnikeys how does that [ __ ]
search it
oh yeah baby oh yeah investigate snake
oh I [ __ ]
hmm
see what they got oh yeah I'll do pick
val tail uh-oh 20 that rubber
so [ __ ] trap search it oh yeah baby
get some wood empty betrayal can [ __ ]
that jet ok [ __ ] kitties that would oh
not you mama all right guys another
episode of adios
how's the schedule is loyalty oh yeah
okay set of expedition no
I'm done I have dark hot is that a
lumberjack farm here yeah
oh great wow those zero-hours magnesium
then cordite I don't need that [ __ ]
leather what else I got what else I got
who might gonna fix that now
and fix that while you're at it snakes
don't belong in Alaska I don't know he
passed what the [ __ ]
hello
I'm sure [ __ ] die have we [ __ ] up
ooh ahh [ __ ] they don't need this
you
come on Andrew come on come on
um [ __ ] what was it going to do I
literally can't hear however [ __ ]
anymore hinges oh I wasn't take
recycling recycle this [ __ ] okay okay
upgrade [ __ ] you still can't do that
this guy is not doing well
whoever some people are going to die
Shannon died oh well harvester will sell
dead meat to next person that's come
plus 24 trauma oh oh oh
oh what what
uncle oh my god hunka [ __ ] died in a
random death Nicholas got irradiated
Shannon Gotti you idiot it's Cindy Lou
get irradiated Jesus ah well I hope
y'all enjoyed pretty [ __ ] up but you
know we're going strong I didn't know
that good people fresh all right